mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
how many solutions does the following
equation have
for a b and c being distinct numbers
here's the equation
it's the sum of four different terms
the first three terms have a similar
form
the first term is a squared multiplied
by the fraction x minus b multiplied by
x minus c
all over a minus b multiplied by a minus
c
then we add the second term which is
plus b squared multiplied by x minus c
multiplied by x minus a
all over b minus c multiplied by b minus
a
then we add the third term
c squared multiplied by x minus a
multiplied by x minus b and that's all
over c minus a multiplied by c minus b
finally we subtract x squared and the
entire equation is equal to zero
this is a multiple choice question
how many solutions are there
the options are 0
1
2
3 and infinitely many
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
rather than trying to simplify
algebraically we'll substitute some
convenient values
let's try for example x is equal to a
we will substitute into the equation and
now let's simplify
now notice we have a term that's equal
to a minus a
but a minus a is equal to zero and zero
multiplied by anything else will be
equal to zero
so this entire term will vanish and be
equal to zero
we also have a factor of a minus a in
the third term
so this will be equal to zero and thus
the entire third term will vanish and be
equal to zero
we now simplify the equation
we now notice another thing that will
simplify
the numerator here is exactly equal to
the denominator
thus this will cancel out to be one
so the equation will be equal to a
squared minus a squared is equal to zero
this is a true statement and therefore x
is equal to a is a solution to the
original equation
so let's put that to the side
and we'll go back to the original
equation
we will similarly substitute x is equal
to b
once we do that we'll also get some
magical simplifications
b minus b is equal to zero therefore
this entire first term will vanish
then b minus b is equal to zero so the
entire third term will vanish
from here we will again have that the
numerator is exactly equal to the
denominator so these will cancel out to
be equal to one
and the entire equation simplifies to be
b squared minus b squared is equal to 0
and that's a true statement so x is
equal to b is a solution of the original
equation
now we'll try one more value which is x
is equal to c
we have a very similar process here
c minus c is equal to zero so the entire
first term will vanish
then c minus c is again equal to zero so
the entire second term will vanish
then in the third term we have the
numerator and denominator are exactly
equal to each other so they will cancel
out to be one
so we have c squared minus c squared is
equal to zero that's a true statement
therefore x is equal to c is a solution
to the original equation
so we figured out x is equal to a x is
equal to b and x is equal to c
are three things that will solve this
equation
now let's do a little bit of analysis on
this equation
in the first term we have x minus b
multiplied by x minus c
so we have a polynomial here of degree
at most two
the same thing is true in the second
term this is a polynomial of degree at
most two and the same thing is true in
the third term
so putting this all together this entire
equation which will just be things that
are at most x squared will be a
polynomial of degree at most two
however we figured out there are at
least three different solutions to this
equation
but we know a polynomial of degree at
most two can have at most two roots
so this cannot be a polynomial of degree
two or degree one it will be equal to
zero
f of x must be equal to zero
so the only way that we can have f of x
is equal to zero the entire thing is
equal to zero would mean these first
three terms
must be exactly identically equal to x
squared
thus this equation simplifies to be x
squared minus x squared is equal to zero
how many solutions does this equation
have
well it's true for every single value of
x
therefore the correct answer is e
there are infinitely many solutions to
this equation
what an interesting algebra problem
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you